what do you think about the movie Her
let me ask you that before I talk before
I talk to you about because it's not
effectiva is and was not just about
emotion so I'd love to talk to you about
smart eye but before that let me just
jump into
um the movie
uh her do you think we'll have a deep
meaningful connection with
increasingly deep and meaningful
connections with computers is that a
compelling thing to you something I
think that's already happening the thing
I love them I love the movie Her by the
way but the thing I love the most about
this movie is it demonstrates how
technology can be a conduit for positive
behavior change so I forgot the guy's
name in the movie
um whatever Theodore Theodore
so Theodore was like really depressed
right and he just didn't want to get out
of bed
and he's done with with life right
and Samantha right Samantha she just
knew him so well she had she was
emotionally intelligent and so she could
persuade him and motivated him to change
his behavior and she got him out and
they went to the beach together
and I think that represents the promise
of emotion AI if done well
this technology can help us live happier
lives more productive lives healthier
lives more connected lives so that's the
part that I love about the movie
obviously it's Hollywood so it takes a
Twist and whatever but but the but the
key notion that technology with emotion
AI can persuade you to be a better
version of who you are I think that's
awesome
well what about the twists you don't
think you don't think it's good for
spoiler alert that Samantha starts
feeling a bit of a distance and
basically leaves Theodore
um you don't think that's a good feature
that's a that you think that's a bugger
feature
well I think what went wrong is Theodore
became really attached to Samantha like
I think he kind of fell in love with us
do you think that's wrong
I mean I think that I think she was
putting out the signal this is an
intimate relationship right there's a
deep intimacy to it right but what does
what does what does that mean what does
that mean AI system right what does that
mean right I'm just friends
yeah
well I think when he realized which is
such a human thing of jealousy when you
really like this was talking to like
thousands of people she's parallel
dating yeah that did not go out right
uh you know that doesn't and from a
computer perspective like that doesn't
take anything away from what we have
it's like you getting jealous of Windows
98 for being used by millions of people
but it's like it's like not liking that
Alexa yeah right it's a bunch of you
know other families but I think Alexa
currently is just a servant it it tells
you about the weather it's not it
doesn't do the intimate deep connection
and I think there is something really
powerful about
that the intimacy of a connection with
an AI system that would have to respect
and play the human game of of jealousy
of Love of uh heartbreak and all that
kind of stuff which the matter does seem
to be pretty good at
I think
she this AI systems knows what it's
doing
I don't think she was talking to anyone
else you don't think so you think she
was just done with Theodore yeah oh she
knew that this yeah and then and she she
wanted to really she wanted to move on
she didn't have the guts to just break
it off cleanly okay
she just wanted to put in the paint no I
don't know well she could have ghosted
him she could have gone
I'm sorry there's our Engineers oh God
uh but I think those are really I I
honestly think some of that some of it
is Hollywood but some of that is
features from an engineering perspective
not not a bug I think I think AI systems
that can leave us now this is for more
social robotics than it is for anything
that's useful like I I hated if
Wikipedia said you know I need a break
right now right right right right like
no no I need you
um but if if it's just purely uh
for for um companionship then I think
the ability to leave is really powerful